He raged at the world, at his family, at
his life, but mostly he just raged. Love
of spirit, anger is suffering. When you
can't act upon it, anger management,
emotional maturity, all that garbage is
all prison. Imagine being this goblin,
angry and free. I mean, you're pretty
useless, but you also have haste, so
you're not going to not attack. Do now
and worry later. Now, imagine finding a
group of friends bonded by anger issues
going in together. Together, you can do
anything and everything, but just once.
But then, imagine impressing a Greek god
with your display of passion, and now
you and your buddies get to do it over
and over again, every day, Edge of
Tomorrow style. And now, imagine your
spectacle attracts crowds, some setting
you up with fire arrows, some looking to
profit off the casualties, and some who
just enjoy watching. And all of a
sudden, you go from a meme to winning
games of EDH. Imagine. If this sounds
like a life you would like to live, we
can be friends. This is Jin with Next
Level Commander, and I'm angry about a
lot of things. And today's deck is an
outlet. Ares, God of War. Whenever an
attacker dies, it comes back. So,
instead of getting punished for a crappy
attack, we get rewarded. So, we just
need to gather a few idiots, okay, like
20, and send them in over and over and
over again until we win. Okay, sounds
pretty stupid. But what if we recruit
some helpers? Then things get more
interesting. Okay, let's get to that in
a bit, but let's introduce the bros,
starting with the ones that do nothing
but attack. These ones are all goblins.
This isn't exactly a goblin deck, but
we've got some synergies. So, 13
goblins. Now, we do have a few that
aren't goblins, but they have to pull
their weight. Rograkh, for example, I
heard is decent, barely makes the cut.
Rabbit Battery is good because with it,
our bigger boys get to attack
immediately as well. Bolt Courier is
probably not going to come to this, but
the exile can be helpful when we are
desperate for cards, and when we are
not, a few wasted exiles is not a big
deal. Then we have Clockwork
Percussionist and Heralded Street Guard.
These two all leave something behind
after dying and when we do it over and
over again, it's pretty good value. And
that's it for the idiots. We are moving
our way up the IQ ladder. Sack outlets
because at first our opponents may
block, but then they will catch on
pretty quickly and figure out that you
actually want the creatures back in your
hand. So, they take the damage. Now, if
your group is dumb, you can skip this
part, but if not, we need them sack
outlets. The ones that fit this deck
best are the one drop ones like Carrion
Feeder, Viscera Seer, Skirk Prospector
and Mak Raider. Now, these ones do
double duty and unlike the big ones with
self-respect, these ones can sack
themselves. And moving on to the more
expensive ones with better value, we've
got Umbral Mantle Seer, Viscera Seer,
Goblin Bombardment, Pawn of Ulamog, and
of course we have the Pawn of Ulamog and
of course we have the Pawn of Ulamog
plus his altar. Yeah, we are going heavy
on sack outlets because we want to make
sure every turn we get to deploy the
squad, send them in, they die, and they
come back to hand. This entire process
needs to be repeated over and over again
reliably because when we do, we profit.
Well, for example, the Plunderer and
Pawn of Ulamog, those care about
non-token creatures and we have the most
disposable non-token creatures in all of
Magic. Grim Haruspex, Midnight Reaper,
and this Garna here, they profit from
our creatures dying. And also, Gorbag of
Minas Morgul and Gix, Yawgmoth's
Praetor. They'll draw us cards when we
do hit. And of course, with this kind of
deck, we need some draining effects.
Unfortunately, we don't get to play
Zergel, but Garna does something pretty
similar. Usually, we get the draw, but
sometimes once in a while we use the
drain effect to finish the game. And
that's our primary win condition cuz in
the early game we will have, you know,
three to five creatures dying every
turn, but later on we can up that number
to seven to 10. And when that happens,
cards like Bontu's Monument and Carter
can do a lot of damage. And even more
efficient are Purphoros and Agathe
Instigator. With these out, we can end
the game fast. Imagine casting five
creatures, doing 10 damage to everyone,
and then when they die and get returned
to hand, we recast them for more damage.
And of course, we can't leave out Syr
Konrad. And what's cool about this one
is that every creature we cycle through
both triggers the dying effect and the
creature card leaving graveyard effect.
So, yeah, also two damage per raging
goblin. In a similar vein, we have
desecrated tomb and Tevesh Szat's
judgement. Yeah, every turn we'll be
getting a bunch of bat tokens and all
three triggers from this easily. And now
some miscellaneous utility. The best of
the bunch is easily sneak attack. This
turns every creature in my hand into a
raging goblin. And sure they die, but
with the sac outlet we can get them back
and especially with our commander in our
hand we can just you know pay five red
mana, sneak everything in, attack, get
them back into my hand, get a bunch of
triggers. It's the best card in the
deck. Yeah, if I push this deck to
bracket three I'm tempted to include a
tutor just for sneak attack. Aside from
that, cool but rude is a cool
enchantment where we get to loot every
turn because we're attacking. And also
the discard part is relevant. Sometimes
we'll get 10 cards in hand and just
discard naturally and we'll get we'll
get six damage just like that. And also
it includes a Goad mode as the final
mode and the costs are super reasonable
and spaced out. It's beyond realistic to
reach all three levels and get the full
benefit. Gadrak, the Crown of Blood
Flame, this is a late game piece that
can just replace our commander once we
have enough mana or if I have a sac
outlet. Lightning Greaves fits well here
and finally Empty the Warrens. You can
easily get four to five storm triggers
and that's a lot of tokens. One
interesting perk with this deck is that
you get to keep a lot of your resources
and engines in your hand. Like if you
want you can sacrifice your commander,
your sac outlets and hold on to them to
be protected from removals or board
wipes. So, in this case cards like
Reliquary Tower and Thought Vessel are
very helpful. This also means we can go
a bit heavier on board wipes since they
can often be asymmetrical. Now, the
Grave Pact effects and Dictate of Erebos
of course go in, but also we want
Blasphemous Act and Blasphemous Edict.
They're just so efficient. Oh, and Toxic
Deluge. We do have enough life gain to
offset the payment. Finally, ramp. Aside
from the boring classic, we do have some
synergistic pieces like Birgi making all
our goblins essentially free. And also
Runaway Steam-Kin is like a mini Birgi.
Curse of Opulence is a bit risky, but I
put it here because I can't think of a
deck that's attacking more consistently
like we do. So, yeah, it probably should
go in here. And that's the full deck.
For lands, mana-fixing is very
important, so we prioritize that.
Actually, I think with the current list
I'm already being a bit greedy with the
utility lands, but we do need sack
outlets. These ones are important. Also,
the MDFCs here have a lot of synergy, so
we include those. But yeah, for utility
lands, we are prioritizing the ones that
make colored mana except Winding Canyons
cuz once in a while we'll be able to go
off during combat, you know, cast,
recast, sack for a bunch of mana, and
all that. And Kher Keep because it's
just so efficient and such a great mana
sink for our deck. And that wraps it up.
The deck is not as explosive as you
might think. Even if we open with a
bunch of goblins, we're not dropping
them just yet. It's too risky for the
few damage we can get. I mean, if we
have some kind of sweet follow-up, sure,
but for the most part, you wait for the
setup, get a bit of ramp, get some value
engines out there, and ideally somewhere
between turn four and turn six you drop
the commander Ares and a few goblins to
begin the onslaught and and do the same
every turn after until the game ends
hopefully in your favor. The deck is
fairly resilient. Like I said, we are
kind of good at dodging board wipes, and
we always keep our hands full, so we're
we don't run out of gas that easily. The
deck is not super easy to play cuz
there's a bit of sequencing to figure
out and also when to drop the goblins,
when to drop the value engines, which
ones to drop, maybe don't be too greedy
and overcommit, and all that. But once
you figure it out, it's really fun to
play. You can come up with some kind of
war chant or even bring a drum or
something to instill fear in your
opponents when you unleash the same
horde for the first, second, or the
fifth time. The budget is medium, but
you can drop it by a few hundred dollars
easily. Nothing expensive here is
essential. I mean, the Sneak Attack is
just $10. What a great deal. Speaking of
great deals, I am sponsored by Kakapopo
TCG. They make excellent sleeves, deck
boxes, and dice, all kinds of products.
Take a look. And if you're interested,
get a discount with my code levels all
caps to get 5% off. And finally, I just
want to mention this deck I have not
tested. The commander was spoiled a few
days ago. And yeah, I spent all my time
testing Captain America. So, this deck I
believe should be somewhere between
Bat-Bracket 2 and 3. And if you want to
load up on Game Changers, a tutor is
nice. Jessica's will can't be bad. And
aside from that, it's up to you.
All right, that's all for today. Thank
you. I'll see you in my next video.